THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
BERMAN [inaudible]
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER FOR THAT [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE [inaudible]
CALDERON CARILLO [inaudible]
CERVANTES CHAU [inaudible] TEN
DAVID CHIU [inaudible]
TROLL A KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY [inaudible]
COOPER [inaudible]
CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
DALLY HE DEEP [inaudible]
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FLORA [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
FRAZIER [inaudible]
FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GABRIEL --
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON [inaudible]
GLORIA.
GONZALEZ IS GRAY [inaudible]
GRAYSON [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE [inaudible]
KILEY.
LACKEY.
LEVINE.
LIMON ALONE [inaudible]
LOW [inaudible]
MAIENSCHEIN.
MATHIS.
MAYES MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK.
QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS.
RAY.
THREE OF US ROB [inaudible]
RODRIGUEZ.
RUBIO.
SALAS SANTIAGO.
SMITH.
STONE.
TING VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER [inaudible]
WICKS [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
MISTER SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE HAVE SET OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OSHA PROMOTION.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
THIS PAST SUNDAY WE OBSERVE THE
ANNUALMARCH RITUAL OF MOVING
OUR CLOCKS AND WATCHES FORWARD
WHEN OUR IN A GREEN TO MAKE ONE
DAY TWENTY THREE HOURS IN
ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE HOURS.
WE ARE REMINDED THAT THE
MEASURING OF TIME IS A HUMAN
INVENTION.
OUR CLOCKS AND CALENDARS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN OUR ATTEMPTS TO
MEASURE THE PASSING OF TIME THAT
IS INTERNET.
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA'S
PARTICIPATION DAY LIFESAVING MAY
SOON END.
I'VE COME TO APPRECIATE THESE
TIME CHANGING RITUALS.
THE GOAL OF THE LIFESAVING HAVE
BEEN OUR ATTEMPT TO MAKE THE
MOST OF THE DAYLIGHT TIME WE
HAVE.
AS THE DAYS GROW LONGER AND
SHORTER THROUGH THE YEAR.
BUT JUST AS THE LIFESAVING HAVE
HELPED US TO MAKE THE MOST OF
THE DAY LIKE TIME WE HAVE
THROUGH THE YEAR.
IT IS A GOOD REMINDER THAT WE
SHOULD ALWAYS BE TRYING TO MAKE
THE MOST OF THE DAYS WE HAVE IN
LIVING OUR ONE AND ONLY LIFETIME.
AS WE'VE OFTEN SHARE.
IF WE TRY TO LIVE EACH DAY WELL.
WE CANNOT HELP BUT IN TIME.
LOOK BACK ON A LIFE WELL LIVED.
NO MOMENT OUT.
FINANCING GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER GABRIEL PLEASE
JOIN ME IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE READY BEGAN.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
[inaudible]
SEE [inaudible]
YOUR ANA --
IS A LITTLE [inaudible]
STRONG.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO TUESDAY MARCH FIFTH
TWENTY NINETEEN DECENTLY MET AT
SEVEN AM ON BOTH PHACELIA AND
AGUIAR-CURRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOURTH JUST PRESIDING CHIEF
QUICKIE DOTSON WILSON AT THE
DESK.
READING CLICK KATHLEEN IS SURE
GLORIA MOVES AND MISTER
GALLAGHER SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS HAVE PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHRISTY SMITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN TALLY AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DEVON MATHIS.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IAN CALDERON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILLIP CHEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
MARIE WALDRON MOVING TO
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MR A BONTA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE ONE
EIGHTEEN HEY.
AND ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO TO HAVE A GUEST AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
HIS GUEST WILL BE SEATED AT HIS
DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER QUEST.
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM TWENTY ACR
FOR FRAZIER.
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY
SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RE REFER THE FOLLOWING BILLS
TO COMMITTEE.
AB TWO FIFTY FOUR QUIRK SILVA
FROM THE TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
A. B. THREE NINE ONE OF VOEPEL
FROM THE PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
AND EIGHTY NINE EIGHTY FOUR
LACKEY FROM THE HEALTH COMMITTEE
TO THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER
MEMBERS WE HAVE
SPECIAL GAS IN THE CHAMBER TODAY
MEMBERS.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO
MS CRISTINA GARCIA WHO HAS GAS
AND CHAMBER IS GARCIA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS IT'S WITH
GREAT PLEASURE THAT I GET TO
INTRODUCE ROTH ACADEMY OF
CREATIVE AND MEDIA ARTS.
MIDDLE SCHOOL NEDC UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT REPRESENTATIVES
TO THE STATE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY.
IN RECOGNITION OF BEING READ THE
SIGN THAT'S ONE OF THE ONE OF
ONLY FORTY NINE SCHOOLS TO WATCH
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IN THE
NATION.
THE SCHOOLS TO WATCH IS THE
NATIONAL STATE OPERATED MODEL
SCHOOL THE THING NATION AND
SCHOOL IMPROVEMENT INITIATIVE
FOCUS ON RECOGNIZING HIGH
ACHIEVING SCHOOL SERVING
STUDENTS IN THE GREAT.
FIVE TO EIGHT STAFF AND THE
SCHOOLS HAVE WORKED EXTREMELY
HARD TO CREATE SUPPORTIVE
ENGAGING COMMUNITIES THAT
ACTIVELY SERVE TO THE ACADEMIC
AND SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF
ALL LEARNERS.
AS I MENTIONED THIS IS A RE
DESIGNATION FOR ROTH MIDDLE
SCHOOL THEY'VE BEEN DESIGNATED
ASSETS SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN THEY ARE ALSO A
CALIFORNIANS THEY WISH MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
ALRIGHT IN SCHOOL AND THE
NATIONAL FORM SCHOOLS TO WATCH
RECIPIENTS.
A MAJOR FOCUS THAT ROB IS TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES AND EQUAL
ACCESS TO ALL STUDENTS.
RESIDENTS ARE CHALLENGING RIGORS
CORE ACADEMIC CLASSES THAT
WORKING COLLABORATION WITH AN
EXTENSIVE ELECT THE PROGRAM THAT
IS ALREADY FOUND THAT A MIDDLE
SCHOOL.
ALL CORE ACADEMIC FEATURES THE
STATE OF THE ART TECHNOLOGY TO
TEACH THE CALIFORNIA COMMON CORE
STANDARDS IN ENGLISH HISTORY
SCIENCE MATH AND PHYSICAL
EDUCATION.
IN A REGION THAT OFTEN MUST
FIGHT AGAINST THE PERSISTENT AND
STARKEY TEAM EVIDENCE.
TODAY IN THE GALLERY PLEASE JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING PRINCIPLE
PRISCILLA RODRIGUEZ.
ASSISTANT PRINCIPAL I'M AND
THAT'S THE LAST.
TEACHER CLAUDIA SOLANO.
TEACHER YOU WE SENATE.
ABC UNIFIED WAR PRESIDENT ERNIE
NISHI.
AND ABC UNIFIED SUPERINTENDENT
MARY SUE.
ON BEHALF OF MYSELF IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU FOR EXCELLING
AT EACH EDUCATED THE NEXT
GENERATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE AND LEADERS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING THE PRIDE OF
THE FIFTY EIGHT IN GIVING ME
SOMETHING ELSE TO BACK ABOUT TO
MY COLLEAGUES CONGRATULATIONS
.
MEMBERS MAY HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
[inaudible]
MR SANTIAGO I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
V. I. P. ON THE FLOOR WITH YOU
TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER SANTIAGO.
I THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME.
SINCE THEN THE OTHER MY KID.
SCHOOL WAS OUT SO HE DECIDED TO
COME UP HERE AND MAKE A LOS AYE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LIKE THE WALKING HIM TODAY AND
CHILD CARE IS REAL AND THEN THE
ISRAEL.
FOR THANK YOU
.
AND MISTER REED YES.
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE GAS IN THE
GALLERY.
I DO THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
THIS MORNING IT'S MY PLEASURE TO
WELCOME RESIDENTS FROM THE CITY
OF MORGAN HILL.
WHO ARE HERE AS PARTICIPANTS OF
LEADERSHIP MORGAN HILL?
AND SIMILAR CONCEPT TO THE MANY
PROGRAMS IN OTHER PARTS OF OF OF
CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP MORGAN
HILL THE NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION.
THAT IS DEDICATED TO TRAINING
AND DEVELOPING OUR COMMUNITY
LEADERS.
THIS LEADERSHIP PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE PARTICIPANTS
WITH IN DEPTH AND ALLAH TO THE
POLITICAL ECONOMIC AND
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURES OF ALL.
OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
PARTICIPANTS WITH US A LOCAL AND
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
YOU PUBLIC OFFICIALS WOULD EVER
CLAIM THAT GOVERNMENT CAN SOLVE
ANY PROBLEM.
BY ITSELF.
BUT WHEN THE MANY PARTS OF THE
COMMUNITY COME TOGETHER AND ARE
INVOLVED IN DEVELOPING A DEEPER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE CRITICAL
ISSUES FACING OUR COMMUNITIES.
IT CAN LEAD TO LASTING SOLUTIONS
THAT BEST REPRESENT THE VALUES
AND DESIRES OF THE DISTRICTS A
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE SO
FORTUNATE TO REPRESENT.
ALSO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT.
AND WELCOME TO OUR STATE CAPITOL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
.
AND MR KILEY [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION TO MISTER
KILEY FOR HIS GUESTS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER WE HAVE
SOME VERY SPECIAL GUESTS WITH US
TODAY -- ALL
AROUND US ACTUALLY IN THE
GALLERY OUR STUDENTS FROM VALLEY
VIEW CHARTER MONTESSORI SCHOOL
IN EL DORADO HILLS.
WE PLEASE JOIN ME IN GIVING THE
STUDENTS ALL ONE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN OF THEM A VERY WARM
WELCOME TO THE STATE ASSEMBLY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
[inaudible]
SECOND READING.
COVERAGE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TO NINETY NINE
WITH AMENDMENTS AND THREE THIRTY
FOUR ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS [inaudible]
ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ITEMS ON THE
THIRD READING FILE.
THIS IS A SIMPLY THIRD READING.
MEMBERS THIS IS ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE AC ARE TWENTY FIVE BY MR
GLORIA.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWENTY FIVE BY SOMETHING MEMBER
GLORIA AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA ATTRACTIONS AND PARKS
DAY.
MR GLORY ON THE RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I'M GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO BRING FORWARD ACR
TWENTY FIVE WHICH RECOGNIZED
TODAY MARCH FOURTEENTH TWENTY
NINETEEN IS CALIFORNIA
ATTRACTIONS IN PARKS DAY.
AND ALSO COMMEMORATES THE
FIFTEENTH ANNIVERSARY OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO MORE THAN
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
ATTRACTIONS NEED A TRACTION AND
PARKS HAVE BEEN VITAL PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S CULTURE.
AND OF OUR ECONOMY.
IN FACT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ALONE VISITORS TO OUR STATE
SPEND APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
AND THIRTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
THIS REVENUE HELP TO SUPPORT
OVER ONE MILLION CALIFORNIA JOBS
AND GENERATE ROUGHLY ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX REVENUES
AT THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL
THAT SUPPORT VITAL COMMUNITY
SERVICES.
ACR TWENTY FIVE ACKNOWLEDGES THE
IMPORTANT ROLE THAT ATTRACTIONS
AND PARKS PLAY IN CALIFORNIA'S
PASS ARE PRESENT AND OUR FUTURE.
THE RESOLUTION ALSO HIGHLIGHTS
THE IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE TO CALIFORNIA'S
TOURISM INDUSTRY BY THE
CALIFORNIA PARKS AT THE
CALIFORNIA ATTRACTIONS AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION.
THE MEMBER PROUD TO REPRESENT
MANY OF THESE ATTRACTIONS SEA
WORLD WORLD OUR WORLD FAMOUS ZOO
AND OF COURSE BELMONT PARK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA.
SAY NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MR GLORIA WITH LIGHT WOULD YOU
LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION YES SPEAKER.
MEMBERS THE FIRST ROLES GOING TO
BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON A C.
R. TWENTY FIVE FOR CLUB THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SIXTY EIGHT CO AUTHORS
ADDED AND WITHOUT OBJECTION.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND MR GLORIA MEMBERS.
PLEASE YOUR ATTENTION MR GLORIA
FOR HIS GAS INTRODUCTION
RELATIVE TO THE RESOLUTION THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER YES WE DO
HAVE SOME HONORED GUESTS HERE
THIS MORNING I'M PROUD
INTRODUCED MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA TRACTION AND PARKS
ASSOCIATION.
THEY HAVE PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN
CONTRIBUTING CALIFORNIA'S
TOURISM INDUSTRY AND THERE
COUNTLESS EFFORTS AT THEIR
RESPECTIVE PARKS ALL THROUGHOUT
THE GOLDEN STATE COLLEAGUES
WOULD YOU PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY.
AND THANKING THEM FOR ALL OF
THEIR HARD WORK.
AND MR DAILY AS WELL ON THIS
RESOLUTION YOUR GAS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
THIS RESOLUTION RECOGNIZES THE
POSITIVE IMPACT THE CALIFORNIA
TRACTION SOME PARTS HAVE ON OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IN MY DISTRICT A PARTICULAR PARK.
ALLOWS US TO TRAVEL BACK IN TIME
TO SCIENTIFIC WORLD INTO VISIT
THE GALAXIES EDGE.
BEYOND CAPTURING OUR CREATIVE
SPIRITS CALIFORNIA TRACTION SOME
PARTS ARE ACTIVE CONTRIBUTORS TO
PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
IT'S MY HONOR TO BE A PART OF
THIS RESOLUTION WITH.
WITH MR GLORIA TODAY.
CALIFORNIA TRACTION SOME PARTS
BOOST OUR STATE AND LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND THEY PROVIDE A LOT
OF FUN AS WELL.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR DAILY.
THAT VOTE HAS BEEN REGISTERED
PREVIOUSLY MISS.
QUIRK SILVA.
YOUR GUESS INTRODUCTION.
I WAS GOING TO ADD SOME COMMENTS
BUT WE'VE ALREADY VOTED SO.
DO YOU YOU CAN PRETEND THEIR
GUEST INTRODUCTION OKAY WELL AS
AS THE MEMBER THAT REPRESENTS
KNOTT'S BERRY FARM THE HOME OF
JELLY AND BOYS AND BERRIES AND
SNOOPY WE ALSO WANT TO WEIGH IN
ON OUR SUPPORT.
AND ALSO AS OF FULLER TEN
COMMUNITY MEMBER THAT WORKED AT
DISNEYLAND.
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND ACTUALLY MY
NAME IS SHERRIN DARLENE AND
THOSE ARE THE NAMES FROM THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES MOUSEKETEER
CLUB SO WE HAVE DEEP ROOTS WITH
DISNEY LAND.
AND WITH NOT VERY FAR.
SO I FULLY SUPPORT THIS ACR.
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS QUIRK SILVA.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
FILE ITEMS FOUR AND FIVE PASS
RETAIN.
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX THIS IS A C. R. FORTY SIX BY
MR MCCARTY.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY RELATIVE TO MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS AWARENESS WEEK.
MR MCCARTY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING A C. R. FORTY SIX
RECOGNIZING MARCH ELEVENTH.
THROUGH FIFTEEN AS MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS AWARENESS WEEK EN
MASSE AS WE KNOW MS I A
DEBILITATING NEUROLOGICAL DE
DISEASE.
AFFECTING THE CENTRAL NERVOUS
SYSTEM EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY THERE NEARLY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
WITH MS IN CALIFORNIA. FORTY
THOUSAND THERE IS NO CURE BUT
THERE ARE TREATMENTS TO MAKE
THIS ELEMENT MORE LIVABLE FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE MS UNFORTUNATELY
THE COST OF THESE THERAPIES HAVE
GONE UP.
NEARLY 4100% IN THE LAST DECADE
CAUSING SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
BURDENS.
SINCE NINETEEN FORTY SIX THE
NATIONAL MS SOCIETY HAS BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR MORE RESEARCH
SERVICES.
EDUCATION PROGRAMS AND HELPING
THOSE AFFECTED WITH MS.
THE SOCIETY OFFERS PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES THAT.
THAT -- ARE
RECOGNIZED ACROSS THE WORLD AND
OUR CATTLE LAST FOR ADVANCEMENT
IN RESEARCH AND GETTING CLOSER
TO A CURE.
I PLEASE JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING A
C. R. FORTY SIX RECOGNIZE IN
THIS WEEK AS MS AWARENESS WEEK
AND OF COURSE I ASK THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS.
THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK TO
THE RESOLUTION.
PLEASE RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE.
IS A MEMBER WISH TO SPEAK TO THE
RESOLUTION.
SEEING NINE MISS MCCARTY'S ASSN
AT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OF THE
ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS MEMBERS.
ALL MEMBERS WE SHOULD ADD AS CO
AUTHORS.
PLEASE DO SO NOW.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS AND A C. R..
FORTY SIX THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL CLOSER ALL THEIR
SEVENTY ONE CO AUTHORS AT ON THE
RESOLUTION.
AND WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
AND MR MCCARTY BACK TO YOU FOR
YOUR GAS INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
JOIN ME IN WELCOMING IN THE
GALLERY INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY.
LEADING THE CHARGE TODAY AS A
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY
STEWART VERY THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US HERE TODAY
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
THE HOUSE WILL BE AN ORDER.
THE HOUSE WILL BE IN ORDER.
MS BURKE THIS IS FILE ITEM.
NUMBER SEVEN AB. ONE FORTY SEVEN
CLOCK RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY SEVEN BY
SOMETHING MEMBER BURKE AND
OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO TAXATION
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
MS BURKE EMAIL.
GOOD MORNING MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB ONE FORTY SEVEN THE WHERE AT
WAYFAIR IMPLEMENTATION AND SMALL
BUSINESS RELIEF ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A COMPREHENSIVE AND
BALANCED SET OPPOSE WAY FAIR TAX
COLLECTION RULES THAT MAKE SENSE
FOR THE CONSUMER.
SMALL BUSINESS AND THE STATE.
AB ONE FORTY SEVEN DOES SO IN
THREE WAYS FIRST WE PROVIDE
RELIEF TO SMALL BUSINESS BY
INCREASING THE ECONOMIC NEXUS
THRESHOLD FROM 1-001-000-2500.
THOUSAND AND ELIMINATE THE TWO
HUNDRED OR MORE TIONS THRESHOLD
ENTIRELY.
THIS PROVISION ALSO HELP THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION BY ELIMINATING
THE COST ASSOCIATED WITH TRYING
TO REGISTER.
AND COLLECT FROM TRULY SMALL
ODYSSEY BUSINESSES WHERE IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES THE COST
OF COLLECTION MAY WAY OUTWEIGH
THE REVENUE GENERATED.
SECOND AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
RECOGNIZES REALITIES OF TODAY'S
ECONOMIST ECONOMY BY REQUIRING
ONLINE MARKETPLACES TO COLLECT
SALES AND USE TAX ON BEHALF OF
THEIR THIRD PARTY RETAILER.
FINALLY AB ONE FORTY SEVEN
PROMOTES CLARITY AND SIMPLICITY
BY REQUIRING RETAILERS TO
COLLECT AND REMIT LOCAL DISTRICT
TAXES ONCE THEY SELL OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND IN CALIFORNIA.
ELIMINATINGTHE BURDEN SOME
REQUIREMENT TO TRACK SALES IN
EACH DISTRICT WITH THAT.
I WOULD NOTE THAT THIS BILL HAS
NO KNOWN OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BURKE.
SEEING IT NO DISCUSSION. FOR
DEBATE ON THE BILL.
CAR CLUB RURAL.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
[inaudible]
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE AYE SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY I
SIXTY FIVE NO.
ZERO ON THE BILL.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS MOVING VERY BRIEFLY TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
DR WORK YES YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR MY DESK IN THE REAR CHAMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I HAVE A VERY SPECIAL GUEST
TODAY --
LEON RAMOS CHAVEZ. THREE MONTHS
ALL -- YOU
KNOW I HAVE A VERY DEDICATED
CHIEF OF STAFF.
BUT AS WE BOTH SAID.
THERE ARE SOME THINGS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN WHAT WE DO HERE.
AND THIS IS TIME.
SHE REALLY NEEDS.
THAT CAN NEVER COME BACK.
WE WILL PASS.
WE WILL PASS BILLS --
WE WILL HAVE OUR CRISES BUT
THERE'S NOTHING LIKE THIS.
SO MY CHIEF OF STAFF TO MáS AND
RAMOS HER HUSBAND HAZY'S PHILLIP
BAY CHAVEZ.
THANK YOU ALL FOR GREETING OUR
NEW CITIZEN
.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WE ALWAYS BREAK FOR CUTE BABIES.
BACK ON THE FILE FILE ITEMS.
EIGHT THROUGH.
ELEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE MR GABRIEL --
ROOM.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
A. B.. FOR TWENTY FOUR COOPERATE.
AT SOME LEVEL FOR TWENTY FOUR BY
SOME MEMBER GABRIEL AND ACTUALLY
THE DEPOSITIONS.
IS GABRIEL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB FOR TWENTY
FOUR WHICH CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW.
REGARDING THE ADMISSIBILITY OF
CERTAIN DEPOSITION TRANSCRIPTS.
CALIFORNIA IS CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF
LICENSE COURTREPORTERS THIS
SHORTAGE IS BECAUSE MANY
ATTORNEYS TO RELY ON ON LICENSE
VIDEOGRAPHERS TO RECORD THEIR
DEPOSITIONS.
WITH A TRANSCRIPT TO BE PREPARED
AT A LATER DATE.
VIDEOTAPE DEPOSITIONS ARE
ADMISSIBLE IN COURT UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS BUT CONFUSION
EXISTS ABOUT WHO MAY LAWFULLY
TRANSCRIBE RECORDED DEPOSITIONS.
AND WHAT IS REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THAT THE TRANSCRIPTS OF THOSE
DEPOSITIONS CAN BE ADMITTED
WITHOUT CONTROVERSY.
AB FOR TWENTY FOUR RESOLVES THIS
CONFUSION BY CLARIFYING THAT
ONLY A CALIFORNIA LICENSE COURT
REPORTER MAY STENOGRAPHY.
TRANSCRIBE A RECORDED DEPOSITION.
THIS BILL PROTECTS THE PUBLIC
AND LET AGAINST FINANCIAL IN
VIDEOTAPED DEPOSITIONS ARE
PREPARED BY LICENSEES WHO ARE
COMPETENT.
QUALIFIED AND ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
COURT REPORTERS BOARD.
AB FOR TWENTY FOUR RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS KAY REAL MISTER
BERMAN YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
SPEAKER A QUESTION FOR THE
MEMBER FROM SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
I KNOW WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU SIR I I FEEL LIKE
WE'VE BEEN SITTING TOGETHER FOR
A DECADE BUT BUT AM I RIGHT THAT
THIS IS YOUR FIRST BILL.
PRESENTED ON THE FLOOR.
MR GABRIEL ADDRESS THAT IN MY
CLASS.
I I BELIEVE I I I BELIEVE IT IS
THE FIRST BILL FOR THE MEMBERS
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND AM I
CORRECT THAT YOU WERE A A
LITIGATOR IN A PAST LIFE.
MR GABRIEL.
I FEEL LIKE I'M HAVING MY
DEPOSITION TAKEN.
SO I I CAN'T HELP BUT ASK THE IT
I AM SURE YOU EXPERIENCE
FRUSTRATION WITH THE POSITIONS I
IN THE PAST NOT THIS YOUR
COMFORT ZONE IS THIS THE TYPE OF
HARD HITTING AGGRESSIVE.
LEGISLATION WE CAN WE CAN PLAN
TO HEAR FROM YOU THROUGHOUT YOUR
YOUR LEGISLATIVE CAREER OR WERE
YOU BRANCH ABOVE YOUR COMFORT
ZONE -- AT
SOME POINT --
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE MY
COLLEAGUE FROM PALO ALTO AND HIS
VERY SINCERE INTEREST IN
PHOTOGRAPHY I KNOW IT'S ONE OF
HIS PASSIONS.
I THINK THAT THIS IN APART BILL
TO PROTECT THE LITIGANTS AND THE
PUBLIC THIS THESE ARE IMPORTANT
MATTERS THAT ARE HEARD BEFORE
THE COURTS AND SO.
THIS IS A SMALL TECHNICAL FIX
BUT I THINK A VERY MUCH BENEFIT
THE PEOPLE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
I COULDN'T AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE MORE LOOK FOR TO
SUPPORTING --
AB.
FOR TWENTY FOUR THANK YOU MISTER
BERMAN I THINK.
DO WE HAVE YES MISTER GALLAGHER
YOUR RECOGNIZE --
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER --
I AM REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE THE AUTHOR.
ACTUALLY USED TO BE A SENATOR.
IN THE A. S. YOU SEE SENATE AT
UC BERKELEY.
AND I I UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO
SERVE WITH THEM --
THERE AS WELL --
HE WAS KNOWN FOR BRINGING THESE
KIND OF BILLS --
YOU KNOW THAT.
WE'RE KINDA WONDERING LIKE WHY
ARE THEY NECESSARY YOU KNOW
THOSE THOSE TYPE OF BILLS ON SO
I JUST I WOULD JUST ASK QUESTION
THE AUTHOR ARMY A WEEK GOING TO
SEE WITHOUT OBJECTION.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER SIR.
HOW ARE WE GOING TO SEE MORE OF
THESE TYPE OF BILLS IN THE
FUTURE --
GOING LOT HARKENING BACK TO YEAR.
YOUR CAREER IN THE ACC SENATE AT
BERKELEY [inaudible]
MR GABRIEL.
I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE HAS
POINTED OUT THAT THAT QUESTION
HAS BEEN ASKED AND ANSWERED BUT
ALL ALL HUMOR MY COLLEAGUE FROM
EASE NICHOLAS SINCE --
WE DO SHARE --
SO MUCH A RELATIONSHIP THAT GOES
BACK MANY MANY YEARS WE'VE HAD.
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE MANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT OUR SHARED.
AFFECTION FOR PRESENT A BOMB I
KNOW WE WERE BOTH GREAT FANS OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
AND I THINK THAT THIS IS THE
KIND OF THING SUPPORT SO I'M
SURE YOU'LL SUPPORTED AS WELL.
I'M MY OWN TIME MISTER SPEAKER
[inaudible]
SHE GALLAGHER.
AS I RECALL --
YOU KNOW I WE BOTH STILL LOOK
VERY YOUNG.
BUT WHEN WE WERE IN COLLEGE.
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH WAS
PRESIDENT AND AND I BELIEVE YOU
DID SUPPORT MY RESOLUTION IN
SUPPORT OF A GEORGE W. BUSH IS
THAT CORRECT.
AS AS I RECALL.
MISSION GABRIEL WAIT WITH
APOLOGIES I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM EAST NECKLACES IS MIS
REMEMBERING THE FAX HE DID DO AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF REPRESENTING
THE BERKELEY COLLEGE REPUBLICANS
HE WAS ONE OF TWENTY MEMBERS OF
THAT.
OF THE STUDENTS SENATE THEY ARE
WHICH IS SOMEWHAT SIMILAR TO OUR
RATIO HERE SO I APPRECIATE HIS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
MR GALLAGHER.
BOB MISTER SPEAKER I AM I AM
WITHOUT WORDS AND THAT'S RARE.
THAT IS VERY RARE.
BUT I DO SUPPORT THIS BILL --
AND I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
TO I I DON'T KNOW THESE EVER
ACTUALLY GIVEN A DEPOSITION
BECAUSE HE WORK FOR THOSE BIG
FIRMS WHERE.
YOU KNOW THEY JUST BY DOING A
CORNER SOMEWHERE BUT BUT ANY
RATE VERY GOOD BILL.
AND I WILL BE SUPPORTERS TODAY
THANK YOU YOU MISTER GALLAGHER.
WELL PLAYED MR GABRIEL.
AND I'VE RUN THIS BILL BEFORE SO
I KNOW IT'S VERY NECESSARY.
MISSION GABRIEL WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
AND ENCOURAGEMENT AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
CLARK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE [inaudible]
CLARK WELL [inaudible]
WHAT'S WRONG.
TELL YOU WHAT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE AND NUMBER.
THIRTEEN MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THERE ARE RESOLUTIONS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR.
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE WILL FIRST TAKE OF
THE RESOLUTIONS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ADDING CO AUTHORS
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE
ONE ROLL CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY
MEMBER TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR
TO THE RESOLUTIONS.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
RESOLUTIONS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA RELATIVE TO RARE DISEASE
DAY HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES RELATIVE
TO INTERFAITH AWARENESS WEEK.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY TWO BY NO EDUCATION
ADVOCACY WEAK AND HOUSE
RESOLUTION ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES RELATIVE TO
ROSA PARKS A HUNDRED AND SIXTH
BIRTHDAY.
CLICK WITHOUT OVER THE ROLE TO
ALLOW INTERNET TO ADD ON AS A CO
AUTHOR TO THE RESOLUTIONS THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTIONS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. FOR THE
RESOLUTIONS I CONSENT.
CLICK WELL CLOSER ALL.
THERE ARE SIXTY NINE CO AUTHORS
ADDED.
MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS A MEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SINGING HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR.
AS IN THE CURRENT RESOLUTION
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMO
AND RELATIVE TO DUAL ENROLLMENT
WEEK.
LOCAL OVER THE ROLE ON THE
COUNTER.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRED ABOUT
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS ARE DESIRED ABOUT
CLARK.
ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO VOTE
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL.
I SEVENTY TWO KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
CLERK WILL READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
IT'S ON THE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
FORTY THREE I SEVENTY TWO NO
ZERO HOUSE RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FORTY TWO
I SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO HOUSE
RESOLUTION ELEVEN I SEVENTY TWO
NO ZERO AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION.
SEVENTEEN I SEVENTY TWO NO.
ZERO SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH FIFTEENTH
NO FLOOR SESSION --
CHECK IN SESSION.
MONDAY IN FLOOR SESSION IS AT
ONE PM.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS RUBIO MOVES AND MR PEROT
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED.
UNTIL MONDAY MARCH EIGHTEENTH AT
ONE PM IN THE QUORUM CALLS
LIFTED